يمثل دونالد ترامب والجمهوريون المهاجرون
التطرف
الذي يهدد أسس
[الموسيقى]
والجمهورية
ولكن بما أنني أقف هنا الليلة
تتعرض المساواة والديمقراطية للاعتداء ،
فنحن لا نفضل أنفسنا للتظاهر
بخلاف ذلك ، فإن
قوى الماجا مصممة
على اتخاذ هذا  بلد إلى الوراء
إلى الوراء إلى أمريكا
حيث لا يوجد حق في الاختيار
ولا الحق في الخصوصية ولا الحق في
منع الحمل ولا الحق في الزواج ممن تحبه
كثيرًا مما يحدث في
بلدنا اليوم ليس
عاديًا
دونالد ترامب والجمهوريون المهاجرون
يمثلون التطرف
الذي يهدد  أسس
جمهوريتنا وأريد أن أكون
واضحًا جدًا في المقدمة ،
فليس كل جمهوري ولا حتى
أغلبية الجمهوريين جمهوريين ماغي
وليس كل جمهوري يعتنق
أيديولوجيتهم المتطرفة
[موسيقى]
كثيرًا مما يحدث في
بلدنا اليوم
هو إدارة غير كفؤة
مستسلمين في هزيمة
سنعيش عليها ولكن للأسف ستصاب بلادنا
[موسيقى]
أنت